Let's knit a test collar with a sandwich
band that can be used
to cover a cut and sew edge.
This could also be used to attach
a collar to a shaped neckline.
Now, this is not a beginner project.
There are a number of steps to construct
this collar, and there are also a number
of skills you must master
or review before attempting it.
The first one is a neat
full needle, rib cast on.
The cast on edge of your collar will be
the focus of your garment,
so be sure you practice and knit
a cast on that you like.
I used the broken toe cast on.
It starts with three slip rows.
Number two, be familiar
with knitting and full needle rib.
Remember, because all needles are on work,
you'll need a thinner yarn than you might
normally knit with on your machine.
Number three,
you must be familiar with setting
your machine for tubular knitting.
We will knit in the round for the pocket
or that sandwich section of this project.
Plus, we will scrap off the ribber
stitches, leaving the main
bed stitches in work.
You also need to be comfortable
with manually pulling stitches
through the knitting.
Now, this can get tricky,
so remove any distractions,
get a good night's sleep, and focus.
You also need to be comfortable
with binding off in the stitch-by-stitch
method with long loops.
Of course, you could scrap off and
hand-knit to secure the last stitches.
Now, if you're feeling comfortable with
all of these skills, let's get started.
Instead of creating a cut and sew
neckline for our test.
I'm just using a surged edge of a swatch.
It isn't even the same yarn as my collar.
No matter, we just want
to practice the steps.
First, determine how many needles
you'll need for your collar.
Hold the edge up against the machine,
stretching it slightly.
Set your machine for full needle rib. Half
pitch, and put the required number
of needles in work on both beds.
Cast on with the method of your choice.
I'm working a broken toe cast on,
which will give me a strand to tighten so
that I can steam and set that cast on edge.
Now, if you aren't familiar with this
cast on, I suggest you give it a try.
Next, measure a collar on a sweater or
a shirt to determine the length you like.
Remember, it's going to fold over,
so you might want to make
it a little bit longer.
This is a good time to experiment.
Knit the desired length of your collar.
Set your machine for circular knitting.
For example, slip to the left on the main
bed, slip to the right on the ribber,
and knit about a half inch worth of rows.
Remember, it takes two passes
of the carriage to complete
a row in tubular knitting.
I knit a total of six rows,
12 passes of the carriage.
We'll scrap off the ribber stitches only
by canceling slip on the ribber and setting
your main bed to slip in both directions.
Remove the main yarn from the yarn feeder
and thread the carriage with scrap yarn.
Knit 4-6 rows of scrap on the ribber only.
Notice that the stitches are going
to bunch up a little bit,
so don't knit too many rows and make
your scrap a good contrasting color.
When you're done there,
after knitting just a few rows,
drop those stitches and drop your ribber.
Notice the pocket that's been created.
Next, we'll attach the garment edge.
With the right side facing up, position
the garment edge across the main bed.
The cut edge of your
neckline will be facing you.
Press that cut edge against the sinker
post to position the cut edge
inside that pocket or sandwich.
Push the main bed needles through the neck
edge, and
re-hang the scrapped-off pocket stitches
from the ribber and position them
in the hooks of the needles.
Make sure you close all of the laches and
carefully pull the stitches through both
the neck edge and the stitches
that are remaining on that main bed.
I removed the waist yarn to confirm
that I picked up all of my stitches.
Oops, I missed one.
You must take care with the laches so they
don't catch on the knitting
and the stitches remain
in the hooks of the needles.
This can be a little tedious.
Take your time.
Flip the garment towards you and carefully
pop the knitting off the gate pegs.
Handknit a loose row
with fairly long loops.
I just hand-knit some large loops and then
pulled loop through loop to bind off.
Now, if you prefer not to have such
a visible bind off, you could
sew those stitches in place.
With all the steps involved,
you can see how things can get a bit
confusing and easily go wrong.
Before trying this technique on a garment,
I suggest you knit at least one other test
collar using the edge of a swatch,
or maybe get brave and use
a sample cut and sew neckline.
With a good mental picture,
I'm sure you will have success.
First, we knit the collar,
leaving it on the machine.
Then we knit in the round
to create the sandwich pocket.
We then positioned the cut edge
in that sandwich and pushed
the needles through the cut edge.
We pulled one-half of the sandwich
stitches through that cut edge
and neatly bound off.
Have fun knitting your sandwich collar.